[Applaudissements]
je vous ai je voudrais vous inviter un
petit voyage par imagination en afrique
en afrique est une afrique fantômes et
je n'ai jamais ni réellement les pieds
en afrique subsaharienne depuis que
j'étais enfant rêver d'afrique grâce à
des objets que l'on perd collectionner
petite collection sa ses livres sur les
cérémonies d'afrique et aussi grâce à la
rêverie des lectures poésie africaine
pour il m'est arrivé d'aller à bruxelles
avec des amies étudiantes et mon père
m'a confié une mission fort
embarrassante donner la somme de 2000
francs ce qui me semblait énorme
il lui est acheté un beau lit dans un
magasin d'art africain à bruxelles donc
lhi m'a expliqué que c'était portes de
petits qu'au fond
ni popo tam mi cheval peut-être que
c'est un chameau on ne sait pas il a une
bosse il est fait d'argile il est fait
de cire d'abeille il est fait de
végétaux et sur le dessus
il a de la patine latine vient des
rituels qui sont pratiqués dessus le
sang séché voulais qu'ils sont sacrifiés
que plumes viennent parfois le parsemer
intérieur il ya des restes animaux cie
peut-être des placenta humain toutes
sortes de choses donc vous comprenez que
c'était une drôle de mission qui m'était
confiée très dans la boutique vu trois
petits boli qui était caché sous une
table et approcher et toucher 1 en avait
un qui était bancale les autres étaient
stables sur sortie de la boutique un peu
décontenancé je suis allé à la cabine
j'ai téléphoné à mon père dit es tu sûr
que c'est vraiment ça que tu veux il ya
quantité de belle statuette quantité de
belles statues quantité de vos masques
veux-tu cet affreux nougat noir de
colmater
du de la noix de cola cracher dessus
également cela dans sa collection et ça
devait être le clou de sa collection vu
le prix il m'a répondu oui vraiment
c'est ça qu'il me faut que il vient de
la culture des bancs bana bana bambara
au mali chargé d'une yamaha et les
charges et des forces végétales gd force
animale et les rejets des forces
humaines ferait peur même un malien
converti au culte musulman ont ils
inspirent les froids du sacré et c'est
celui-là qu'il me fout si on rentrait
dans la boutique acheter celui qui était
bancale parce qu'il y avait eu une
histoire avec les faux qui était fait
pour les européens qu'il fallait essayer
de trouver les réellement servi à des
rituels
fort embarrassée parce qu'il était très
très très lourd beaucoup plus lourd que
ce qu'il semblait disions un bol y fait
environ 20 kg raid ans il est compact et
de toute l'histoire de ces rituels nous
passions sous le bras parce qu'ils
étaient lourds jusqu'à la voiture
nous rions à moitié amusé à moitié
embêté quand même avec cette affaire
qu'ils ont d'avoir fait quelque chose de
mal qui nous a même jeté un sort qu'il
allait jeter sur nous une malédiction
arrivé à la maison je les cacher
derrière un canapé ce cas ci puisse
rejouer son heureux propriétaire
quand je suis arrivé à paris chez mon
père pour les remettre son bolide montré
une photo qui était assez étonnante et
une photo du palais de l'elysée où on
voyait le président de l'époque monsieur
jacques chirac
mais un beau lit au dessus de lui sans
doute que ça devait lui conférer un
certain pouvoir parce qu'il se piquer
d'art africain et qu'il voulait ou frais
ouvrir le mais le musée des arts
premiers
l'actuel musée du quai branly qui a
effectivement ouvert en 2006
ce musée a ouvert ils me suis rendu en
espérant y trouver des boli est
effectivement à 2 dans les collections
du musée du quai branly
il était installé près d'une pièce où il
y avait des vidéos sur les cérémonies
d'afrique
penché sur le cartel donnant les
explications sur le lieu de provenance
de cet étrange animal était indiqué qu'
il servait à des rituels macula qu'il
avait été obtenu non sans violence par
donc l'équipe de la mission dakar à
djibouti qui avait permis de remplir les
musées du musée du trocadéro et indiqué
que sa référente c'était 71 1931
quand tu es 11 parce qu'il provient du
musée du trocadéro qui s'est transformée
en musée de l'homme qui s'est
transformée en musée du quai branly et
1931 puisque c'est l'année où il a été
capté
ce nom sans violence qu est ce que cela
voulait dire pour cela il faut lire
l'afrique fantôme de michel leiris qui
était le secrétaire de la rédaction du
journal qui devait donner les
indications chaque jour de ce qui a été
fait par la mission les risques qui s à
l'époque c'est un poète un peu
désoeuvrés bail avec les surréalistes
qui est en mal d'aventuré et il souhaite
être le nouveau en rade
conrad c'est un auteur qui est d'origine
polonaise mais qui s'est naturalisé
anglais célèbre pour avoir écrit au
coeur des ténèbres
un célèbre livre que les connaître a
directement puis il a été transposée à
l'écran dans apocalypse now par francis
ford coppola
régine au coeur des ténèbres raconte la
remontée par marleau un marin d'un
fleuve
on suppose qu'il s'agit du congo puisque
je faisais jaune joseph conrad était
allé au congo
il essaye de remonter le fleuve pour
aller rejoindre un certain courte ce qui
est à la fois trafiquants d'ivoire et
poète rimbaldien réussi à capter
l'esprit de la brousse donc ils espèrent
se michel leiris rencontré quelque chose
de noir quelque chose il dort et quelque
chose de doux son du sacré ressentir en
afrique et dans ce voyage de l'afrique
fantôme est de raconter
il a essayé de d'éprouver cette afrique
fantôme
commence fort mal puisque dès le début
il dit que à peine le voyage commence et
il se rend compte que n'est pas encore
venu le jour ils vont dénudée sur place
une famille pour leur avoir acheté tous
leurs vêtements mais que cela ne saurait
tarder on sent l'ironie cynique du livre
qui se rapproche un petit peu du voyage
au bout de la nuit parfois d'un certain
céline
il arrive au mali et le 6 septembre 1931
se passe quelque chose d'affreux j du
vol du coc know it et ils sont censés
acheter les objets officiellement arrivé
à la casse du kono qui est l'endroit ils
font les rituels pour le beau lit elle
non seulement avoir un sacrifice sur le
kono ce qui n'est pas du puisque
normalement il faut attendre un rituel
initiatique pour y avoir droit
ils veulent acheter l'objet
or un chrono un beau lit ça ne s'achète
pas c'est hors du but du marché de l'art
ceux qui ne comprennent pas et vous
devinez la suite il vole le kono comme
le dit michel leiris
on n'est pas peu fier quand on est un
blanc et qu'on a un revolver dans la
poche
vivement quelques jours après il se rend
compte de l'énormité de ce qu'ils font
mais ils continuent les pillages il
continue des vols et cela se poursuit
sur plusieurs journées africains sont
évidemment effrayés ils fuient dès que
les blancs harry puisqu'ils savent très
bien ce qu'ils viennent faire
recul au fur et à mesure où ils avancent
elle devient une afrique réellement
fantôme puisque ils ont trop de violence
pour comprendre et pour partager
se passe ensuite heureusement pour
michel leiris sait qu'il va faire
changer son voyage de mort
à commencer par la découverte de la
langue sacrée des dogons 200 gars il va
s'arrêter la mission continue en pour
découvrir cette langue sacrée voir sa
poésie très proche de la sienne révéré
en fait les interprètes des liens
d'amitié avec eux
poursuit heureusement aussi avec un
amour qu'il voue à une magicienne qui se
livrent à des rituels de possession des
arts s'est elle même la fille d'une
autre magicienne quand ils arrivent en
ethiopie il peut serrer l'afrique
fantôme contre lui elle est en chair et
en os contre lui il peut interagir et il
ne s'agit plus du pillage d'objets mais
en ethiopie des fresques entières sont
arrachés des murs elle figure
actuellement au quai branly
sous prétexte de les restaurer elles
sont embarquées
sans la volonté des indigènes en dans
nos musées vous pouvez toujours les
ivoires qu'est ce que c'est que ce beau
lee qu'est ce que c'est que ce que nous
est ce une oeuvre d'art pouvons-nous la
ramener en afrique puisque c'est
évidemment ce qui nous vient à l'esprit
une fois qu'on a pris conscience de son
histoire c'est la question que
actuellement viennent de se poser
bénédicte savoy effet lwin ça dans un
magnifique livre qui est le résultat
d'un rapport d'un livre que vous pouvez
le dire puisqu'il vient d'être publiée
qui s'appelle restituer le patrimoine
africain
ils se demandent précisément qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire avec ces objets ils
sont missionnés par notre actuel
président monsieur macron pour réaliser
des inventaires des objets et dialoguer
avec les peuples africains pour produire
quelque chose de plus heureux que le
pillage
par contre de nombreux problèmes
embarrassantes se pose maintenant à nos
amis ethnologue eux
on peut bien sûr faire des musées en
afrique il en existe le problème c'est
qu'ils sont souvent pied par les
occidentaux eux-mêmes ou par les
africains qui revendent bien sûr sur le
marché de l'art on les comprendrait donc
ses heures et récemment j'ai discuté
avec des amis qui ont oeuvré au musée
des civilisations noires au sénégal ils
m'ont dit en aparté discrètement qu'il
faisait le listing des objets qu'il
voulait ne pas y voir figurer de peur
qu'ils disparaissent raconté aussi qu'
il ne s'agissait pas de se présenter
comme ethnographe mais comme sociologue
pour ne pas faire peur aux africains et
que les musées étaient parfois un peu
vite parce que les africains eux mêmes
n'ont pas la culture du musée on les
comprend
98 % de leur patrimoine se trouve en
occident ils n'ont rien à transmettre ni
pour transmettre l'histoire du
colonialisme du postcolonialisme ni pour
raconter la magie de leurs ancêtres et
sebo rituel puisque tout est chez nous
bien sûr nous les avons conservé c'est
sûr et il serait mieux bien sûr à
retourner dans la case du connaît aussi
le problème de notre conception
européenne de la conservation des objets
le bolide n'est pas bien fait pour être
sous verre il est fait pour être
restauré il est vivant en afrique les
statuts nes et elmer dire que on les
conserve par des rituels qui les rendent
magique qui les rendent vivant pour une
population pour laquelle elle prend sens
ils sont fait aussi pour être régénérée
c'est à dire que quentin boli s'effondre
eh bien on reprend un morceau et on
refait un autre beau lee oui ne meurt
jamais il est conservé par la société
qui s'en occupe
peut-on ramener le bolide mon père parce
que lui peut-être qu'on a plus prise sur
lui
et bien non vous décevoir parce que
quand j'ai demandé à mon père de me
prenne pour qu'il devienne célèbre sur
lattes hélix et bien il est allé au
grenier
là où il est remisé puisqu'il ne peut
pas l'exposer dans son salon
car ma belle mère apparemment en a un
petit peu peur et on la comprend dray a
trop envie de déjeuner avec le beau lee
ils étaient remises et là haut et il m'a
dit impossible de transporter le beau
lit comme le banques si la faire raser
récemment avec beaucoup d'ironie à la
galerie sauce be il s'est littéralement
autodétruit devant ses yeux puisque il y
fait d'argile qu'il est fragile et qu'il
faut des conservations particulière pour
le vivifier donc faut imaginer ce boli
qui est qui a fait la meilleure action
qu'ils puissent faire pu faire et c'est
à dire retourner à la terre pour nous
poser question et nous mettre en
question nous les occidentaux par
rapport à nos rapports par rapport à ces
oeuvres que l'on veut conserver agnel
le bolide ne veut ni être exposés il ne
veut pas être dans un musée visiblement
il ne veut même pas retourner en afrique
il veut juste retourner à la terre de
ses ancêtres peut-être magiquement il a
disparu
peut-être qu'il ya une nouvelle mission
qui incombe aux occidentaux en mal
d'afrique et pâle d'exotisme et qui ont
envie réellement de découvrir la fri une
nouvelle mission qui suppose d'être
attentif sur nos ondes ce qu'on entend
de l'afrique chantôme à travers les
émissions de radio c'est la guerre c'est
la famine les pénuries
on entend aussi parler de ses fantômes
qui disparaissent dans la mer à l'heure
actuelle je vous jure je vous parle
c'est à dire décembre 2018
hier douze personnes sont disparues en
mer et nous n'avons pas été capables de
les repérer et de les sauver nouvelle
mission certainement qui nous reste à
faire c'est de ne pas oublier que
l'afrique frappe à nos portes
l'histoire frappe à nos portes et des
africains arrivent en chair et en os
chez nous à nous de créer le lien avec
eux c'est à nous non pas de réparer
l'histoire on voit bien que le mal est
fait pas difficile de ramener le kono
mais par contre ce qu'on peut faire bien
sûr ne pas laisser dans l'anonymat ces
personnes cette afrique qui arrivent
chez nous qui a pour nom ahmed à la buba
car ghislain dont le nom ne dit pas
qu'il vient du cameroun depuis six mois
et de ne pas les laisser être simplement
des numéros d'inscription sur un
registre pour s'inscrire à l'université
de philosophie
et laisser au rang de numéro sur un
dossier pour devenir demandeur d'asile
mais à les connaître à connaître leur
histoire savoir l'heure qu'ils ont à
partager avec nous toute la richesse de
leurs pratiques qu'elles soient
religieuses magique ou bien qu'il s'agit
de la vie sociale de la vie familiale et
je voudrais terminer pour pour parler de
cette cette nouvelle mission aussi de
leurs rêves
parce que quand ils viennent au terme
d'un voyage qui n'a rien d'un voyage de
plaisance viennent en france il espère
beaucoup dans la france il espère que la
france soit peut-être ce musée ou soit
conservée depuis 1789 les valeurs que
sont la liberté l'égalité la fraternité
faire en fait arrivé là pour partager
ces valeurs avec nous
c'est à nous de faire en sorte qu'il ne
reste pas au statut de fantômes fantômes
qui sont même parfois leurs propres yeux
puisqu'ils ont tout laissé derrière eux
famille leur apparaît presque
fantomatiques
nous avons à les aider à communiquer
avec leurs familles trouver un
smartphone
c'est une tâche non le pape est simple
trouver donc une voiture à moins de 3000
euros pour qu'ils puissent réagir un
travail leur trouver des logements leur
donner nos clés s'ils sont expulsés
temporairement toute autre chose
un fêter le ramadan alors qu'on n'est
pas musulman toutes choses qu'on peut
faire leur faire faire du surf leur
faire faire du kayak puisque à lannion
on peut en faire
donc c'est cela que sur lequel je
voudrais terminer par un mot d'ordre qui
pourraient être partagées par beaucoup
d'associations ici je ne suis pas
heureusement seuls à le partager
et je voudrais le dire en anglais pour
que ce soit entendu par tout le monde
partageons tous que nous avons cher en
week end
[Applaudissements]